[Music]  one of the big questions that everyone  was asking before the film came out is  why are Batman and Superman fighting  that is the question which is answered  very brilliantly in the film but before  you see the film you don't know why  they're fighting we have a theory as to  why they're fighting I take you now to a  movie Ben and Diane that you made  several years ago called Hollywood land  we're still right here  [Laughter]  [Applause]  you're the past everybody has a past  Batman slept with Superman's mom  now we go man must find out on some  level you must know I think so  yeah super smell this is possibly the  greatest show of everything  [Applause]  you